I was talking to one of my students and
mentioned how years ago one of my
co-workers had put a coke can in a lab
chiller and it had blown up and the bits
had damaged the pump of the chiller and
then I suddenly thought what would
happen if we put a coke can in liquid
nitrogen so late last night I went out
and bought two cans of coke this was a
first for me
I've never bought cans of coke and I've
never tasted any you never tasted I've
never tasted coca-cola one little sip
not a sip are you allergic to it or man
it just doesn't appeal to me and now
I've got to this age I don't want to
spoil my record I might be the oldest
non coke drinker in the world No then I
persuaded Neil that it was worth doing
as you can expect when the can was
dropped in the nitrogen started boiling
a lot what I was interesting is that co2
is quite soluble in cold liquid but it's
not soluble in ice it's poorly soluble
so of course what should happen is that
when the coke freezes the co2 should
come out as a gas and the pressure
should go up at the same time because
ice is less dense than liquid the liquid
in the coke can should expand but
because liquid nitrogen is pretty cold
the co2 may well solidify so the effect
will be less than if it was a gas so
what I was expecting is that the can
would break
I hoped quite spectacularly
and the first time we did it it was
quite exciting because the can split
before all the coke had frozen a slit
almost as if it had been cut by a knife
appeared in the side of the can and the
coke came out and of course as soon as
the liquid with coke is mostly water and
some sugar as soon as it came in contact
with the liquid nitrogen it froze but
there was much babbling so it froze into
a sort of froth a bit like a water ice
in the end what came out looked like an
artwork and I persuaded Grady and Neil
that we should watch it melting and I
got quite excited going back and looking
to the professor was more excited by the
motor than anything we did odo the
second can which we did rather better
with better lighting things like that
was very disappointing
because it froze completely before the
can split and the can split again but
everything inside was solid so nothing
came out what was quite interesting is
that when you look through the slit the
ice instead of being a solid lump was in
much smaller pieces
it's not quite like sand but quite
powdery that didn't surprise me because
I've known for many years that if you
put ice in liquid nitrogen it does crap
finally Brady thought we ought to be
fair and we ought to do Pepsi as well as
Coke
have you tried Pepsi I haven't tried
Pepsi either okay I include them as the
same sort of thing unfortunately the
Machine we've got only sells bottles of
Pepsi so freezing a plastic bottle of
Pepsi we expected it to split in much
the same way
but in fact it was very disappointing
because the bottle froze completely
without splitting at all I got bored and
left
Brady and Neal couldn't restrain
themselves from tasting the frozen Pepsi
but I kept my pledge it's nice and warm
but I suppose gold-color also gives you
a feeling of warmth so it may be partly
psychological the reason why the bank
has got this store is because not only
the Bank of England but other central
banks like to keep some of their money
reserves in gold